the next question comes from
mick west i'd like to ask lou elisondo
does i'll just read this verbatim if he
really thinks this is non-human
technology that can revolutionize the
world and maybe
include contact with aliens and
extra-dimensional beings and so on why
is he so
concerned with ndas surely for the good
of humanity he should release the
evidence
that he has ah surely for the good of
humanity and then
he can go ahead and pay for my mortgage
he can put my kids through school he can
come visit me every day and give me soup
while i'm behind bars
spending the next 40 years of my life uh
you know doing a service for for for
somebody else i've already put my neck
on the line
uh so i'll do respect mr west um you
know uh if
why don't you there's nothing stopping
you why don't you do it you know i've
already put my career
my my reputation and credibility on the
line i've already forgotten my
my retirement and my pension how much
more else do you expect me to sacrifice
you want me to put myself up on a cross
and nail myself to it
just just because you know i think we've
come pretty far so far i think
i think i haven't had to go to jail and
we've come pretty damn far in the last
three years
you know so i guess a simple you're
welcome uh
is probably you know would be my
response